the place broke out just before eight
o'clock on the hotel's top
floor the response closed roads near las
vegas boulevard and harmon
as hotel guests were evacuated madison
kimbrough joins us live from the scene
tonight with the latest on this
developing story
madison
yes sasha it has been a very very active
day in vegas and this really just
tops off the night as a fire broke out
around 8 p.m
on the 51st floor of the cosmopolitan
hotel
take a look from the scene of earlier
here it is as clark county fire
department found
smoke in the hallways of the hotel
leading to what was a fire on the
balcony
the fire was quickly extinguished
however smoke
continued to linger in the air several
hotel guests and employees were taken
out on stretchers
ccfd responded with a total of 10
fire engines four ladder trucks
four rescues two squads and four
battalion chiefs and a total of 72
personnel
but it looked like it was something
serious because there's a lot of
ambulance fire department and a lot of
cop cars and they kept coming
you know not just a few but a lot and
then we noticed that they were going in
through the side entrance
so we knew it was something bigger you
know than just a standard
emergency
multiple people inside the hotel were
transported to sunrise hospital with
minor injuries the cause of the fire is
still under investigation
as of now that is all we know at the
moment but of course we will keep you
updated
and keep it here on 8 news now as well
as 8newsnow.com
reporting from the strip madison
kimbrough 8 news now